okay oh now I posed the question to you
and I wonder if you if you had some time
to think that or were too busy getting
salesman's I said this in asymptotes
through here my question is how do you
know oh how can you tell remember I'm
trying to think about this in a visual
sort of way right
how would you argue for the asymptote
what is in essence right could you
define it out some time for okay that's
a good start
that's a good start align that okay
can't be crossed can we can we go any
more than that they're just awesome
tracing Jenna okay good good so together
right on line that can't be crossed
unless you're horizontal again sir
there's mica despite the disappointment
because the reason why we treat our
crosses is because we're approaching it
and we're approaching it endlessly at
least at a particular place okay now why
do how do I know that we're going to
approach this line y chose X what's
Wigan approaching
good good good good okay did you catch
that did you catch it
let's try that again okay
remember how I argued it or why I argued
that we were going to be close to this
line over here I got my ruler out right
and I said well look it's gonna be the
bottom line plus a little bit and that a
little bit specifically was this
distance here right that distance now
the important thing for you to get is
that this distance is shrinking right
because there's an asymptote here right
it's shrinking shrinking it's gonna
shrink forever that means this distance
over he will also shrink and shrink
forever okay so you hasn't turned up
here implies an asymptote down there
does that make sense
okay so visually that's a really
important it again all right
now I said there's another essence right
here in the middle but it's there for a
different reason sort of okay how do you
know there's an S into there
this is a vertical asymptote right so
vertical asymptotes come from domain
issues right there where the graph can't
exist you truly can't cross a vertical
asymptote right so looking at this
pattern of function because X equal zero
breaks that part that means x equals
zero breaks the line which is a little
more obvious when you look at the whole
thing as one fraction okay so therefore
I know what's happening over there
now what happens on the right hand side
okay I could keep on doing the same
thing and using this argument what's
what's more significant where is it
going that kind of thing but you can do
something a little sneakier than that
which is you can look at these two
component functions this is why we spent
so long at the beginning right and
notice these are not just any functions
so they have special functions right and
you can see that in the green grass
right there special because they have
particular clients of symmetry right
what kind they're all right this one's
on and so is this one
when you add two odd functions right
yeah it's two up functions you're gonna
get another up function can you see you
can almost see it happening right and
now let me argue for visually right over
here close to this x equals zero
asymptote right this functions more
significant and I'm going to be up here
plus a little bit cuz I've got a little
positive value so I'm going up like that
in exactly the same way y equals x is
still the oblique asymptote and I'm
gonna be here plus a little bit that
distance again
you get yes okay so that was it addition
of ordnance okay now like I said you
could have gotten that shape just by
doing this okay when we get to these
other graphs you need to know this purse
off we'll look at the graphs what are
they doing how are they behaving okay
all right now let's look at this and I'm
gonna ask you to do one by itself at
this time I'm going to change the
addition to a subtraction